do you bring veal back in for the shot
yeah that's what I was thinking for a
minute thought they could probably throw
him back in there they got protons
instead the other night
he's the inbounder here gets it back too
much room for him to shoot makes the
most of it
33:27 Philadelphia leading burton's for
three this time he knocks it down
hitting a little bit of the rim he's now
to a 4 from three-point land
is Schmidt to Burton's not the guy you
leave open Thomas Burton's again he's
three for three from downtown 11 off the
bench spacing is so important
you see ished is coming down playing
with excellent pace Smith for Burton's
again for three and Thomas Burton's is
perfect so far in three for Al Horford
Burton's difficult are you kidding me
flame thrower Linda now look at the
degree of difficulty like I played with
a lot of office of mine the guys know a
tough pass to catch and he just still
found his rhythm and his groove it there
you go again stays perfect
to Damas Burton's the Wizards have a
chance to take the lead here Eris able
to put it in he's got 26 now she owes a
good crossover Burton's a deep three yes
back on track
[Applause]